never in modern history has a sitting
president
campaigned from the white house a
political symbol
that's supposed to be for all americans
i profoundly accept this nomination
for president of the united states
but donald trump has again broken with
precedent as he accepted the republican
party's nomination
and attacked his democratic rival joe
biden
this is the most important election in
the history
of our country trump spoke for more than
an hour
painting an apocalyptic picture of a
biden presidency
he told voters his opponent was
campaigning as a democrat
but would usher in an ideology much
further left
than any other liberal candidate your
vote will decide whether we protect
law-abiding americans
or whether we give free reign to violent
anarchists
and agitators and criminals who threaten
our citizens trump touted what he saw
as some of his administration's
successes in foreign policy
i could not sit by
as career politicians let other
countries take advantage of us
on trade borders foreign policy and
national defense
a domestic policy even as trump has
scored low marks from american voters
for his pandemic response
with more than 180 000 americans dead
trump argued biden will not make things
better
instead of following the science joe
biden wants to inflict a painful
shutdown
on the entire country his shutdown would
inflict
unthinkable and lasting harm on our
nation's children's
families and citizens of all backgrounds
as he spoke more than a thousand guests
most of them not wearing a mask
sat shoulder to shoulder ignoring the
white house's
own social distancing guidelines earlier
in the day
democratic vice presidential nominee
kamala harris
hit back charging trump didn't do enough
in the early days of the pandemic to
protect americans
all we needed was a competent president
one who is willing to listen
willing to lead take responsibility
have a plan do their job
harris also accused trump of stoking
racial divisions
absent from trump's speech was any
mention of jacob blake the man
shot in the back last weekend in
wisconsin by a white police officer
even though the incident has caused
nights of protests
and the shutdown of the country's
biggest sports leagues
and in true trump fashion his speech and
the convention
ended literally with a bang
[Music]
but in an attempt to drown out the
festivities protesters marched through
the streets around the white house
demanding justice and vowing to do all
they could to prevent
trump's reelection but donald trump is
undeterred by the pushback in an effort
to build momentum
following his accepted speech he's
immediately hitting the campaign trail
on friday he'll travel to the u.s state
of new hampshire
to hold his first political rally since
the republican
national convention kimberly hellcat al
jazeera
the white house